hey everyone divolo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over one
of the inherited techniques passed down
in the xenon family this technique was
first seen in the battle between naobi
xenon and the special grey curse dagon
this technique is called projection
sorcery or more well known as the fps
technique but before we get into the
meat and potatoes of this ability
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and leave a like on the video if you do
enjoy my content as it really helps out
with the algorithm but anyway
let's get into this technique so firstly
i just want to start off with a little
bit of history relating to projection
sorcery technique
according to ogie zenin it wasn't
because of ogi's technique that he
wasn't picked as the leader of the clan
but because naobita was born with a
natural sense of strategic movement and
near perfect timing he said exactly that
the technique doesn't have much of a
history
obviously this is in reference to it
being an inherited technique one
comparing it to megami's shikigami
technique which is another inherited
ability of the xenon family it is
unknown whether naobiso created this
technique or inherited it when he was
younger
but we do know that one of his sons
naoya zenin has also inherited this
technique now let's get into this
technique
okay so if you're a hakugamer or into
cinema and graphics then i'd imagine you
most likely or already somewhat
understand the core physics of this
technique
for everyone else who doesn't know what
this technique does and what makes it so
potent is that it divides one whole
second into 24 frames of animation
or movement using the field of view as
the projection you can imagine the
projection as like the tv screen
now better says do you know how many
frames are in one animated sequence this
is because this technique works by
tracing a predetermined set of movements
just like an artist for an animated film
would draw 24 different pictures for
just one second of an animation
a user of the projection technique is
allowed to animate himself into the
predetermined moveset that he has chosen
and executes those movements during that
single second if you decide to move with
this technique it makes the person using
this ability appear to move
unrealistically fast both when aoya and
naobiso
are using projection sorcery they are so
quick that not even special grey curses
can keep up with them
while in the action of using projection
sorcery anything that gets touched by
the palm of the user must also abide by
the conditions and follow the 24 fps
rule when they move
if the person touched fails to follow
this rule they are frozen in an
animation frame for one entire second
this is what we see when now beta tunes
dig on into a picture frame and the same
with naoh when he turned maki into a
frame then proceeded to kick her
sending her flying across the field even
though the technique only allows one
second for the user to make its attack
before the enemy can move again it is
still extremely effective as the users
of projection sorcery
are extremely fast and can comfortably
attack during that one second after the
user hits the frame holding someone in
it
it will cause the frame to break and the
target will get sent flying out usually
heavily damaging them
while this ability is full of strengths
like being able to increase your speed
and trapping your opponents momentarily
there are also several risks
this predetermined course of movement
cannot be changed once it started if
they decide to try and change the
trajectory of their movement or the laws
of physics they are also frozen being
unable to move for the rest of that
second
so it can pretty much backfire on its
user and result in them being vulnerable
to attacks
there is also a ceiling to the exertion
placed upon the user's body while
accelerating with this technique
i assume that's why they can't do 60
movements a second instead of 24
though if they maintain constant
activation of the technique speed will
continually build up
so perhaps they might only be able to
start off a movement with 24 frames a
second but if they continually use the
ability they may be able to increase it
but that is still completely unknown
i feel like the best way you can get a
sense of how this ability works is going
into
say sony vegas or premiere pro and
putting in any of your favorite anime
clips and zooming in so that you can see
just one whole second then count how
many times that clip has movement
throughout the second most likely
if there is constant movement in that
second it will have 24 individual
pictures that make up that whole second
of animation
now played at normal speed and try
counting each individual movement for
that second
this is the unrealistic astonishing
speed that someone who uses projection
sorcery can move it there is no possible
way that you are going to be able to
track where they go
anyway i know this was a bit of a
shortened video but i think i've said
everything that i know
myself about the ability and how it
really works if you have all enjoyed my
content and want to see
more explained videos then be sure to
hit that subscribe button and drop a
like on the video if you finally
understood how this technique works be
sure to comment down below what you
think about this technique yourself
and whether you think we will see anyone
else in the series use it
but for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
in a bit bye
you